you know you get told a lot in high
school
what you can't do and you get it from
all sides you get it from
your teachers your classmates
but not here in this program
you are going to get told over and over
what you can do because
i just saw what you can do so don't let
anyone and i mean anyone
ever stand between you and the goals
that you
set for yourself whoa nat hold up
you're gonna get the credit you deserve
i'll make sure that you think that's
what's bothering me
i know i shouldn't have taken the blame
and i certainly don't deserve the credit
will
stop just stop my whole career
from med school on i keep running into
the same problem
men who either dismiss me or patronize
me who cannot see me as an equal
well i see you as an equal no you don't
and it's not just today it keeps
happening
natalie look i know you love me but in a
way that's part of the problem
you can only see me as the woman you
love the woman you need to protect and
take care of
and in a way that limits me it puts me
in a kind of jail
i don't want that natalie let's talk
about this
we'll figure it out maybe we can
but right now i need a break okay i love
you
but i need a break from us oh come on
my partner could have died back there
you step aside this is a hospital our
priority is to treat patients not to
make a rest
as soon as he's out of surgery and awake
he's all yours get me that blood or
you're under arrest
what charge obstructing a police
investigation you're being ridiculous
get me that blood
do what you have to do
maggie take the phone
you don't have to do this stay back
[Music]
i've been meaning to say it was a real
ballsy move way you stood your ground at
that no-win scenario
yeah thanks
hope you enjoyed chief nevin's talk on
station management this morning
now back to the fun stuff we'll be
performing a zero visibility simulation
with blackout masks and live fire
you all have been grouped together for
days now i expect you've gotten to know
each other well
so i'll let you choose the incident
leader for the first run
i nominate stella kidd i
second that third
all right the good chief knows how to
handle an axe
and lay hoes but also commands the
respect of those under him
or her as incident leader
you'll be responsible for getting your
team in and out safely
i will be keeping time
copy that chief
hold our ground oh yeah i'm holding our
ground all units we're at the dead end
on levitt
he's cornered but it looks like he wants
to rush us
[Music]
nice job ladies
it goes i don't know it just came out
shut up
i don't have some deep dark past that
made me want to become a cop i became a
cop because i wanted to i'm actually
from saint charles
yeah i was supposed to have a real
different life than this mirror college
marriage and babies
when i told my family that i wanted to
be a cop they laughed
my boyfriend at the time he um asked me
if i needed attention
everyone at the academy told me i was a
bad fit and for like two years
every time i did something right my fto
looked at me with complete shock
but i wanted it i wanted to be something
different than what i was
knew i could see i don't think people
need to end up anywhere near where they
started
hey did you check your ipad i sent you a
senior cruise's chart
she's still in the vent but i don't
think she's gonna make it
sorry to hear that she's really close
with her mom
it's just the two of them we should
allow her mom in here to sit vigil
you know there's strict protocols in
place yes and the only two reasons that
we would make an exception to them ever
or if the patient is a minor or facing
imminent death
is sunny is both let her mom have this
one last moment
april she's testing positive for covet
as recently as this morning that negates
everything
ethan she needs her mom i'm sorry i
really am
but if the mother's exposed it's a risk
she's willing to take that's not a
decision she's allowed to make ethan
i'm sorry
you wanted to know when you're being a
hard ass
this is it
i'm gonna try something
ugh
yes
yeah i got it
what took me so long come on
john randall chicago pd we just want to
add
targets
oh we got him we got him
stop
good kill me come on man
yeah i'm good yeah you are
you